my big joke with my producers or my
friends is i said when jesus calls you
better pick up the [ __ ] phone
because inspiration
it doesn't come all the time when does
it come to you when when like i'm in the
shower i can hear radio shows i heard
our whole interview in my i was born
this way in the shower you did yeah why
is it the shower is that where you're
most relaxed
i think it's because i'm not thinking
about anything and i'm just you know
water on my face and soap in my ears so
take me through that you're in the
shower you hear born this way in your
head do you run out of the shower yeah
and and grab no i scream to my friend
get my phone and what comes to your mind
the lyrics for the song the tune what is
it i
and i was like oh that's good oh that's
really good it's that simple yeah and
then i just screamed get my phone and
then i uh and you sing it into the phone
yeah i sang it into the phone and then i
left it and then uh
uh we were in liverpool and i thought oh
this is home of the beatles let me just
uh let me just
visit this a little bit so what do you
do when do you save these little tapes
that you make when you sing into the
phone i would think as a fan that would
be interesting to hear you would have
put out just the origins
with me these are the ones you're
currently working on oh i'm actually not
going to play those i'll play it oh
please i don't want to hear what's on
your table i can't play it please you're
about to do it and you backed off why
well because i don't know if there's a
new one and i don't want you to hear a
new one because you'll hear someone else
doing it oh no they won't they're not
gonna do that let me just play something
what do you have an iphone
is that an iphone or a blackberry it's a
blackberry why don't you have an iphone
i do because i have really long nails on
the black because you can't type on
these not good for a brooklyn nail
all right let me hear what you got
[Applause]
there's judas
this is called judas
this is judas from the album
yeah this is the song that's already out
so
why do you have it on there
because i recorded it on my laptop and i
uh i
recorded on my phone and i sent it
to the producer i see that's how that
works
hold on a second let me find another one
yeah find something in there
what do you record that on just like
[Music]
fall in love tonight
is that the first time you ever did
[Music]
i didn't use that end part i probably
should have that was pretty good so then
and then you save it on there yeah
[Music]
i don't even know i sound really wasted
that could be a hit i'm going to steal
that
[Music]
sounds like a beatles record i probably
was drunk
[Music]
it's that simple huh i gotta get it well
it's not that simple but
you gotta get the idea